welcome everyone to this
uh tutorial on the cradle build tool
here in this one we are going to talk
about what exactly is a credit build
tool and how we can use
it and in this one uh we will be also
working on some demos and some
hands-on to understand that how we can
make use of gradle for performing the
build activity
so let's begin with uh the first
understanding that what exactly is
incredible all about
now griddle isn't kind of a build tool
which can be used for the
build automation performance and it can
be used for various programming
languages
primarily it's being used for the java
based applications
it's in kind of build tool which can
help you to see that how exactly
automatically you can prepare the builds
you can perform the automations earlier
we used to do
the build activity from the eclipse and
we used to do it manually right but with
the help of this
build tool we are going to do it like
automatically without any
manual efforts as such here there are
like a lot of activities which we will
be doing during the build process
primary there are different activities
like compilations linkage packaging
these are the different uh tasks which
we
perform during the build process so that
we can understand that how the build
can be done and we can perform the
automations uh this uh
process also it's kind of a standardized
because
again if you want to automate something
standards or a standard process is
something which we require for that
before we
been going ahead with that part so
that's the reason why we are getting
this
build tool because this build tool helps
us to do a standardization process
to see that how the standards can be met
and how we can proceed
further with that part also it's
something which can be used a variety of
languages programming languages
java is the primary language for which
we use the gradle but again other
languages like scala
android cc plus plus ruby these are some
of the languages for which we can use
the same tool
now it's actually using like it's
referring to as an
trophy based domain specific language
rather than xml because
ant and maven these are the xml based
build tools but this one is not that
dependent on xml it's using the groovy
based domain specific language dsl
language is being used here
right now um again uh it's something
which can be used to do the build
uh it can further only be used to
perform the test cases automations also
there and then further on you can deploy
to the artifactory also that okay i want
to push the artifacts to the artifactory
so that also that part also you can get
it done over here
so primary this tool is known for doing
the build automations for the big
and large projects the projects in which
the source got the amount of source code
and
the efforts is more so in that case this
particular
tool makes sense now gradle includes
both the pros of
maven and and but it removes the
drawbacks or whatever the
uh issues which we face during these two
build tools so it's
helping us to remove all the cons which
we face
during the implementation of ant and
maven and again again
all the pros of and maven is implemented
with this cradle tool
now let's see that why exactly this
griddle is used because that's a very
valid question that what is the activity
like
what is the reason why we use the gradle
because um
the first one is that it resolves issues
faced on other build tools
that's a primary reason because we are
already having the tools like maven
and and which is available there but
primary this
griddle tool is something which is
removing all the issues which we are
facing with the implementation of
other tools so these issues are getting
removed
as such second one is that it focuses on
maintainability
performance and flexibility so it's
giving the focus on that how exactly we
can manage the big
large projects and uh we can have
flexibility that
what different kind of approaches i want
to build today i want to build in
different ways tomorrow the source code
modifies gets added up
so i have the flexibility that i can
change this build script so i can
perform the automations
so a lot of flexibility is available
which is being supported by this tool
and then the last one is like uh it
provides a lot of features a lot of
plugins
now this is one of the uh benefit which
we get in the case of maven also that we
get a lot of features
but again when we talk about cradle then
it provides a lot of plugins like let's
say that
normally in a build process we do the
compilation of the source code but
sometimes let's say that we want to
build an angular or a node.js
application now in that case me
may be involved in running some command
line executions some command line
commands just to make sure that yes we
are running the commands and we are
getting the output
so there are a lot of features which we
can use like there are a lot of plugins
which is available there
and we will be using those uh plugins in
order to go ahead and in order to
execute those
builds process and doing the automations
now let's talk about the cradle and
movement because again
when we talk about maven like it was
like something which
was primarily used by the java but again
when we are talking about cradle so
again it's just uh being used primarily
for the java here but what is the reason
that
we prefer gradle over the crea maven so
what are the different
reason for that let's talk about that
part because this is very important
we need to understand that what is the
reason that gradle is preferred as an
better tool
for the java as compared to maven when
we talk about for the build automation
here
now the first one is that the uh gradle
using the groupie dsl language domain
specific language whereas the
maven is considered as in project
management tool which is uh
creating the palms or xml file format
files
so it's being used for the java project
but xml format is being used here
and on the other hand gradle is
something which is not using the xml
formats and
whatever the build scripts you're
creating that is something which is
there in the groupie based
dsl language and on the other hand in
the pump we have to create the
xmls dependencies whatever the
attributes you are putting up in the
maven
that's something which is available
there in the format of xml the overall
goal of
the gradle is to add functionality to a
project whereas the goal of
the maven is to you know to complete a
project phase like to
work on different different project
phase like compilation test executions
uh then uh packaging so uh then
deploying to artifactory so these are
all different phases which is available
there
into the maven but on the other hand
griddle is all about adding the
functionality that how you want to
have some particular features added up
into the build scripts
in gradle there are like we usually
specify that what are the different
tasks we want to manage
so different different tasks we can add
up into the case of gradle
and we can override those tasks also in
case of maven
it's all about the different phases
which has been happening over here
and it's in sequence manner so these
phases happens in the sync was
order that how exactly you can build up
the sequence there
but in case of gradle you can have your
own tasks custom tasks also and you can
disrupt the sequence and you can see
that how the different steps can be
executed in a different order
so maven is something which is a phase
mechanism there
but gradle is something which is
according to the features or the
flexibilities
now gradle works on the tasks whatever
the task you want to
perform you uh it works directly on
those tasks there
on the other hand uh maven is something
does not have any kind of inbuilt cache
so
every time you're running the build so
separate uh
things or the plugins and all these
information gets loaded up
which takes definitely a lot of time on
the other hand
gradle is something which is uh using
its own internal cache so that can make
the
builds a little bit faster because it's
not something which is doing the things
from the scratch
whatever the uh things is already being
available in the cache so it's just pick
that part
and from there it will proceed further
on the build automation and that's a
reason why
cradle performance is much faster as
compared to maven because
it uses uh some kind of a cache in there
and then helps to
improve the overall performance now
let's talk about the gradle installation
because this is a very important aspect
to be done because when we are doing the
installation
we have to download the cradle
executables
right so let's see that what are the
different steps
is involved in the process of the cradle
installation
so when we talk about the gradle
installation so there are primary four
steps which is available the very first
one is that you have to check if the
java is installed now if
the java is not installed so you can go
to the open jdk
or you can go for the oracle java so you
can do the installation of the jdk on
your system
so jdk8 is something you can uh most
commonly use nowadays so you can install
that
once the java is downloaded and
installed then you have to do the gradle
uh
download cradle there now once the
gradle binaries are executable
or the zip file gets downloaded so you
can add the environment variables
and then you can validate if the gradle
installation is working fine as expected
not
so we will be doing the gradle
installation into our local systems and
uh into the windows platform and we'll
see that
how exactly we can go for the
installation of cradle and we'll see
that
what are the different version we are
going to install here so let's go back
to the system and see that how we can go
for the gradle installation
so this is the website of the jdk of a
java oracle java
now here you have different jdk so from
there you can do whatever the
option you want to select you can go
with that so jdk8
is something which is most commonly used
nowadays like its most comfortable
or compatible version which is available
so
in case you want to see that if the jdk
is installed into your system all you
have to do is that you have to just say
like java
hyphen version and that will give you
the uh output that whether the java
is installing to your system or not so
in case my system the
java is installed but if you really want
to do the installation
you have to download the jdk installer
from this website
from this oracle website and then you
can proceed further on that part
now once the jdk is installed so you
have to go for the cradle installation
because gradle is something though
which will be performing the build
automations and all that stuff
so you have to download the binaries
like the zip file probably in which we
have the executables and all
and then we have to have have some
particular environment variables
configured so that we will be able to
have the
system modified over there so right now
we have got like the pre requests as in
java version installed
now the next thing is that we have to
install or download the executables
so uh in order to download the latest
gradle distribution so you have to click
on this one
right now over here there are different
options like you want to go for 6.7 now
it's they having like binary only is or
complete
we'll go for the binary only because we
don't want to have the source we just
want the binaries and the executables
now it's getting downloaded it's around
close to 100 mb of the installer which
is there
now we have to just extract into a
directory and then the same
path we need to configure into the
environment variable so that in that way
we will be able to see that how
the gradle executables will be running
and it will give the
complete output to us over here in this
case so it may take some time and once
the
particular modifications and the
download is done then we have to extract
it and once the extraction is done
so we will be able to go back and uh
have some particular version or have the
configurations
established over there so that let's
just wait for some time and then we will
be continuing with the environment
variables
like this one so once the installation
and the extraction is done now we just
have to go to the downloads
where this one is downloaded we have to
extract it
now extraction is required so that we
can have the setup like
we can set up this path into our
environment variables and once the path
is configured and established we will be
able to start further on that part
on the execution so meanwhile these the
files are getting
started let's see so we already got the
folder structure over here
and we will see that we will give this
path here
there is two environment variables we
have to configure one is the cradle
underscore home and one is the
um in the path variable so we'll copy
this path here
so meanwhile this is getting uh
extracted we can save our time and we
can go to the
environment variable so we can right
click on this one properties
in there we have to go for the advanced
systems settings
then environment variables now here we
have to give it like
gradle underscore home now in this one
we will not be going giving it till the
bin directory so that
only needs to be there where the gradle
is extracted so we'll say okay
and uh then we have to go for the path
variable where we will be adding up a
new entry
in this one we will be putting up till
the pin directory here because
the gradle executables should be there
when i am running the gradle command
so these two variables i have to
configure then okay okay
and okay so this one is done so now you
have to just open the command
prompt and see that whether the
execution or
the commands which you're running is is
completely successful or not
so meanwhile it's extracting all the
executables and all these things
it will help us to understand that how
the whole build process or how the build
tools can be integrated over there
now once the extraction is done so you
have to run like cmd
you have iphone version to check the
version of the java
and then the gradle
underscore version is what you're going
to see that you check the version of the
cradle
which is installed and now you can see
that it says that 6.7 version is being
installed over here in this case
so that's the way that how we are going
to have the cradle installation
performed into our particular system so
let's go back to the content
let's talk about the credit core
concepts here now
in this one we are going to talk about
what are the different core concepts of
cradle are all about
the very first one is the projects here
now a project
represents a item to be performed over
here to be done
like deploying an application to a
staging environment performing some
build
so gradle is something which is required
uh the projects
um the gradle project which you prepare
is not having multiple
tasks which is available there which is
configured and all these tasks all these
different tasks needs to be executed
into a sequence
now sequences again is a very important
part because again if the sequence is
not meant
properly then the execution will not be
done in a proper order so that's the
very important aspect here
tasks is the one in which is a kind of
identity in which we will be performing
a series of steps
these tasks may be like compilation of a
source code preparing a jar file
preparing a web application archive file
or er file also we can have like
in some tasks we can even publish our
artifacts to the artifact tree so that
we can store those artifacts into a
shared location so there are different
ways in which we can
have this uh particular tasks executed
now build scripts is the one in which we
will be storing all this information
what are the dependencies what are the
different tasks we want to refer
it's all going to be present in the
build.gradle file there build.gradle
file will be having the information
related to
what are the different dependencies you
want to download and you want to store
there so all these things will be a part
of the build scripts
now let's talk about the features of
cradle what are the different features
which we
can use in case of cradle here
there are different type of features
which is available there so
let's talk about them one by one so the
very first one over here is the high
performance
then high performance is something which
we can see that we already discussed
that
in case you are using a large project so
gradle is something which is in better
approach as compared to maven because of
the high performance which we are
getting
it uses an internal cache which make
sure that you are using like you are
doing the builds faster
and that can give you a higher
performance over there
second one is the support it provides
the support so it
yes definitely provides a lot of support
on how you can perform the builds
and it's being the latest tool which is
available there so the support is also
quite good in terms of
how you want to prepare the build how
you want to download the plugins
different plug-in supports
and the dependencies uh information also
there
next one is multi-project build software
so using this one you can have multiple
projects in case in your repository you
have multiple projects say
so all of them can be easily built up
with the help of
this particular tool so it supports
multiple project to be built up using
the same
gradle project and uh gradle scripts so
that support is also available with this
gradle a build tool uh incremental
builds are also
something which you can do with the help
of cradle so if you have a
not only the incremental changes and you
want to perform only the incremental
build so that can also be possible with
the help of a griddle here
the uh build scans so we can also
perform the build scans so we can use
some
uh integrations with scenarcube and all
where we can have the
scans done to the source code on
understand on how the
build happens or how the source code
really happens over there so that
code scan or the build scans can also be
performed with this one
and then uh it's a familiarity with java
so for java it's something which is
considered as in by default not even
java in fact
android which is also using the java
programming language is using the
uh particular cradle over here so that
the build can be done
and it can gain uh benefits out of that
so
in in all the manners in all the
different ways it's basically helping us
to see that how
uh we can make sure that this tool can
help us in providing a lot of features
and that can help us to make a reliable
build tool for our java based projects
or
any other programming based project here
right now let's see that how we can
invert a java project with the cradle
here
and uh for that we have to go back and
cradle is something which is already
installed we just have to create
a directory where we can have like how
we can perform some executions we can
prepare some
build scripts and we can have a
particular execution of a
gradle build happened over there so
let's go back to the machine
okay so we are going to open the
terminal here and we will see that how
we can create it
so first of all i have to create a
directory structure let's say that we'll
say like
gradle hyphen project
now once the project is created so we
can go inside this directory so to
create some critical related projects
and preparing the files
now uh in this one we'll let's first
create
a particular one so we will be saying
like vi
build dot gradle so in this one
we are going to put like a two plugins
we are going to use so we are going to
say like
apply plugin
java and uh then we are going to say
like
apply plugin
application so these two plugins we are
going to use
and when we got this file over here in
this one so it shows like build.gradle
which is available there in this case so
two of these files are available
now if you want to learn like you know
what are the different tasks so you can
run like
griddle tasks command over there so
griddle task will help you know that
what are the different tasks
which is available over here by
processing the build scripts and all
so um this will definitely help you to
understand on
giving you the output so here all the
different tasks are being given
and it will help you to understand that
what are the different tasks you can
configure and you can work over here
just like jar files clean and all that
stuff build compile
then it is there then all these
different executions
assemble then javadoc then build then
check test all these different tasks are
there
and if you really want to run the gradle
build so you can run like cradle clean
to perform the clean activity because
right now you are doing like a build
so before that you can have a clean and
then you can run a
specific command or you can run the
griddle clean build
which will perform the cleanup also and
it will at the same time will have the
build process also performed over there
so build and clean up both will be
executed over here
and what is the status whether it's a
success or a failure that will be given
back to you
now in this case in the previous one if
you see that when you run the clean
the cradle clean it was only running one
task but when you go for the
uh build uh process when you run the
cradle
clean build it's going to give you a
much more information
in fact you can also give me further
information like you can have the hyphen
iphone info flag also there
so that if you want to get the details
about the
uh different uh tasks which we which is
being executed over here
so that also you're going to get over
here in this one so you just have to put
like hyphen iphone info
and then all these steps will be given
back to you that how these
tasks will be executed and the response
will be there
so that's a way that how you can create
a pretty much simple straightforward
project
in form of gradle which can definitely
help you to run some couple of cradle
commands
and then you can understand that what
are the basic commands you can run and
how the configurations really works on
there right let's go back to the main
content
right now let's move on to the next one
so in the next one we are going to see
that how we can prepare a griddle build
project
in case of eclipse now we are not using
the a local system we are not directly
creating the folders and the files here
we are actually using the eclipse for
performing the creating a new cradle
project over here so let's move on that
part
okay so now the eclipse is open and i
have open in this one the very first
thing is that
we have to do the gradle plugin
installation so that we can create new
projects on cradle
and uh then we have to uh configure the
path that's how the gradle
plugin can be configured on the previous
uh preferences and all that stuff and
then we will be doing the build process
so the very first thing is that we have
to go to the eclipse marketplace
in there we have to search for gradle
so once the search is done
it will show us the plugins related to
gradle so we have to go for
build ship gradle integration so we'll
click on the install
it will proceed with installation it
will download it in some cases maybe
it's part of the eclipse as an
in the id so you can go to the installed
tab and you can see that
also that if this plug-in is already
installed or not but in this case we are
installing it
and once the installation is done we
just have to restart the
uh specific ones we have to restart this
uh eclipse so that the changes can be
reflected
so it's downloading it's downloading the
cradle here and once that is installed
we will be able to use it over here in
this case in this scenario so we have to
just wait for that part
so still downloading the jar files so
once the jar file is done
it's now over there isn't downloaded so
after that we will be able to proceed
further on that download password
so it's going to take some time to
download it and once it's done
we will be able to proceed further now
once the progress is done so it's asking
us for the restart now
so uh before that uh we just have to
click on restart now and then the
eclipse will be restarted all together
again here so you can do it manually or
you can
go for that options it just require a
restart so that the
new changes can be reflected over here
so the plugins can be activated and
can be referenced here now we have to
just uh put up like
the you know the configuration where we
can have the
system so we can go for the gradle
configuration so we can go for windows
and then preferences now in this case we
have to go for the uh
for the ones in which the cradle option
is available there so cradle is what we
are going to select
now user home the gradle user home is
what we need to use right so
you want to go for the gradle you want
to go for local installation so
so all these options you can use you can
if if you go for the griddle wrapper
then it will be downloading the cradle
locally and
it is going to use the griddle w or
griddle w dot bat file
but if you already have an installation
locally so you can prefer that also
right now in the previous demo we have
already got the
griddle uh extracted so we just have to
go for the
downloads and the downloads already
gradle is available so we are going to
select that part here so this is what we
are going to select
right so this represents that this is
the directory structure in which we
are having the uh mechanism so you can
either go for the build scan so you can
select the build scan also
so once this is enabled then all the
projects will be scanned and will be you
know published
and uh it's in kind of an additional
option which is available
if you really want to disable it you can
disable it also and you can go with this
configuration
so so uh this is where the particular
gradle folder
is being put over here in this case and
then we have to just click on apply
and we just have to click on apply and
close so with this one the
particular execution is done now we will
be going for the project creation so you
can right click over here
or you can go to the file also so here
we are going to go for the
job project and in this we are going to
have a gradle project so cradle project
is what we are going to create here
and next
we are going to say like cradle
project and then
next
so once that is done so finish
so uh with this one when you create the
project so what will happen that uh
automatically there will be a folder
structure will be available there
right and uh there are some uh gradle
scripts which will also be created there
so we will be
doing the modifications to there and
we'll see that how the uh
particular gradle build script looks
like and how we can we will be adding
some couple of uh
selenium related dependencies and we'll
see that how we can have more and more
dependencies added and what will be the
impact of those dependencies on the
overall project
so that also it's very important aspect
to be considered so let this processing
we happen over there it's just creating
and uh
some plugins and binaries are getting
installed and getting downloaded
so we'll see that once the project is uh
imported completely executed over here
and got
created we can extract that now if you
see here the particular option is
available about the gradle tasks
so you can extract it also and you will
be able to know that what are the
different tasks which is available there
let's see that in the build they are
running like build these are the
different tasks which is happening
inside the
build process so gradle executions will
be also available over here in this case
and gradual tasks will be different it
will be represented over here in this
one
so you just have to extract on the
gradle project
okay so this is the library which is
available now uh
what happens that you will be able to
have like settings.gradle in this one
you will be able to have like okay
gradle hyphen project is something which
is available there in this one so that's
what we're being
referring then we have over here as in
these folder structures which is created
like source
main java this is the one source test
java is the one which is available as in
the folder structure
and so test resources are also available
here
so the main source main resources are
also available
now in this case what happens that these
are the dependencies
project and external these are the
different dependencies are available
there
so let's see let's add another
dependency over here in this one in the
build.gradle script and see that how we
can do that
if we open build.gradle file so you can
see that these dependencies are there
like
test implementation junit is available
there
right and then we have a implementations
of this one which is available now these
jar files which you put up
it will automatically be added up as in
part of this one as in part of the
particular dependencies over here and uh
which means that you don't have to store
them as an
within the repository and automatically
they can be happened over there
so let's open a dependency page so we
will be going to mvn repository where we
will be
opening a dependency link so this is the
dependency link here so j
selenium iphone java is available and it
can give you the uh dependency for all
the different options
now we have for maven this is the one
and for gradle this is the one here
so we have to just copy this one and we
have to use it as an dependency so
this is the group and this is the name
and the version which we are using here
now we have copied this one so we will
go back to the
eclipse so here we have to just put that
dependency
and we have to just save it so uh
this is something which is providing
like selenium dependencies which is
available so now we have to just refresh
the project
so right click over here then you will
be able to see the options in the gradle
saying that refresh gradle project now
once the movement you do that
so you will be able to do like for the
first time maybe it will take some time
to download all the dependencies which
is related to selenium
but after that you will be able to see
like the dependencies will be simply
added up over here in this case
so you can see that all the selenium
related dependencies are added up
for any reason if you comment these ones
and you say like synchronize again
so you will see that all the
dependencies which you are adding up
from this selenium
represent uh from the selenium
perspective will be gone back again
so this is the way that how you can keep
on adding the dependencies which is
required for preparing your pale
for your source code and from there you
will be able to proceed further on the
execution part
so that's the best part about this
cradle here so that's a way that how we
are going to prepare a greater project
within the eclipse and now you can keep
on adding like the source code in this
one
and that's the way that how the code
base will be added up over here
right so that's the way that how the uh
particular uh
executions or this uh gradle project is
being prepared in case of
eclipse so that's it for this uh whole
uh
module in which we understood that how
the gradle really works on and we saw
some
on projects also to clearly get an idea
about what is
in gradle build tool all about and how
we can perform the various automations
on this part
so that's it for this one thanks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here